ALSO, RETURNING TO A POSITION HE
HELPED WITH THE TALIBAN BEFORE
THE 9/11 ATTACKS.
JOE KENT IS A RETIRED ARMY
SPECIAL FORCES AND FORMER CIA
PARAMILITARY OFFICER.
HE JOINS US NOW TO REACT ALL OF
THIS LATEST CHAOS.
JOE, CAN YOU MAKE SENSE OF THIS?
>> THERE IS NO SENSE TO BE MADE.
THE ONLY LESSON WE CAN TAKE IS
WE CANNOT NEGOTIATE WITH
TERRORISTS FROM A POSITION OF
WEAKNESS.
GOING BACK TO THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION THAT HAS BEEN THE
LESSON, THE DISASTROUS BERGDAHL
DEBACLE THAT PUT THE TERRORISTS
BACK IN POWER AFTER THE GOT A
U.S. TAXPAYER-FUNDED VACATION TO
GITMO ESSENTIALLY.
THEN THE DEAL THAT BIDEN FAILED
TO NEGOTIATE WITH THE TALIBAN TO
GET ALL THE AMERICANS OUT.
THIS SHOWS THAT THE CULTURE FROM
THE TOP MATTERS WHEN THE
COMMANDER IN CHIEF AND UNELECTED
BUREAUCRATS DON'T CARE ABOUT
AMERICA'S STANDING IN THE WORLD
AND THEY VIEW US AS JUST ANOTHER
NATION ON THE DECLINE, THIS IS
EXACTLY WHAT HAPPENS.
CONTRAST THAT WITH FOUR YEARS OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND NEGOTIATING
FROM A POSITION OF POWER, IT'S A
NIGHT AND DAY DIFFERENCE.
WE HAD THE ABILITY TO GET ALL OF
OUR PEOPLE OUT UNDER
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
HE NEGOTIATED A DEAL THAT
WOULD'VE HAD US OUT OF
AFGHANISTAN THE SUMMER OF 2020
UNTIL THE PERMANENT RULING
CLASS, UNELECTED BUREAUCRATS
MADE UP INTELLIGENCE ABOUT
RUSSIAN BOUNTIES THAT RESULTED
IN THE UNIT PARTY LEAVING US IN
AFGHANISTAN.
THAT IS EXACTLY OUT WE GOT TO
THIS POINT RIGHT NOW.
THEY DIDN'T WANT PRESIDENT TRUMP
TO SUCCEED IN THAT PUT US IN
THIS POSITION OF WEAKNESS.
HE GOT 13 GREAT SOLDIERS KILLED
AND NOW AMERICANS ARE HELD
HOSTAGE WITH OUR
STATE DEPARTMENT ABSOLUTELY
HELPLESS.
>> Brian: WHAT IS AMAZING AS
WE TOLD THEM TO HAVE A DIVERSE
INCLUSIVE GOVERNMENT AND THEY
DIDN'T.
I'M SHOCKED THEY DIDN'T LISTEN.
WE SAID HAD AN INCLUSIVE
GOVERNMENT, DID THEY NOT
UNDERSTAND?
DID THEY NOT HAVE A TRANSLATOR?
WE GOT RID OF ALL OF THEM.
EXCUSE ME, THE TRANSLATORS WE
DIDN'T GET OUT.
AMONG OTHER PEOPLE IN AN
IMPORTANT POSITION, I DETONATED
GLOBAL TERRORIST BY
WASHINGTON WHO WE HAVE ON A
WANTED LIST FOR $10 MILLION, SO
WE COULDN'T GET THAT GLOSSY HAD
SHOT FROM SO WE WERE FORCED
TO USE THE MUG SHOT WE HAD UP.
HOW'S THAT FOR INCLUSIVE?
>> IT IS ABSOLUTELY RIDICULOUS
AND THAT SPEAKS OF THE
RELATIONSHIP WE'VE HAD WITH
PAKISTAN.
WHEN WE NEGOTIATE FROM A
POSITION OF WEAKNESS IT ONLY
LINES THE POCKETS OF CORRUPT
GOVERNMENTS AND LOBBYISTS IN
WASHINGTON, D.C.
PEOPLE CAN HIDE OUT IN THE
PAKISTANI BORDER, KIDNAP
AMERICANS, RUN TERRORISM
OPERATIONS, SEEK SANCTUARY WITH
PEOPLE WHO ARE PROVIDING U.S.
AID TO EVEN WHEN THEY GET CAUGHT
RED-HANDED HOSTING BIN LADEN
THERE, WE CONTINUE TO POUR USAID
INTO THEM.
OUR PERMANENT RULING CLASS IS AN
ABSOLUTE DISGRACE TO ALL OF THE
LIVES THAT HAVE BEEN LOST OVER
THERE.
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT I AM RUNNING
FOR CONGRESS, TO BRING
ACCOUNTABILITY TO OUR PERMANENT
RULING CLASS.
THAT IS WHY IT WAS ON AT THE
PRESIDENT TRUMP PROVIDED ME WITH
HIS ENDORSEMENT TO BRING THE
AMERICA FIRST AGENDA BACK TO PUT
AN END TO ALL OF THE SUCCESS OF
WASTED ALL OF THE LIVES BEING
TAKEN BY THE HUBRIS AND THE
HUBRIS AND LIES OF THE PERMANENT
RULING CLASS.
>> Brian: I REALLY THINK WE
NEED A PRESENCE IN THE AREA.
I DID NOT WANT TO GIVE A RIGHT
TO THE TERRORISTS AND ALREADY
ONE OF THE PEOPLE INFECTING THE
NEW TALIBAN GOVERNMENT DIRECTLY
LINKED TO AL QAEDA, HE WAS THE
LIAISON BETWEEN THE TWO WHICH
LED TO THE 9/11 ATTACKS.
KEEP IN MIND TOO, GORDON, THE
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF NATIONAL
INTELLIGENCE SAID THIS A BETTER
FUTURE OF INTELLIGENCE
OPERATIONS.
WE HAVE TO USE SOME
NONTRADITIONAL PARTNERS NOW TO
FIND OUT WHAT IS HAPPENING IN
THE REGION.
CHILD IS DOWN, RUSSIA, CHINA,
IRAN AND PAKISTAN WILL HAVE TO
BE OUR EYES AND EARS IN THE
REGION.
CAN YOU PLEASE TELL ME WHAT
JOE BIDEN HAS BEEN DOING THE
LAST 50 YEARS THAT HE BROUGHT US
THIS MESS.
>> THAT IS AN ABSOLUTE LIVE.
WE HAVE THE ABILITY TO COLLECT
INTELLIGENCE WITHOUT HAVING A
PERMANENT MILITARY PRESENCE
THERE.
WITHOUT PROPPING UP THESE
MADE-UP GOVERNMENTS.
THE PROBLEM IS LIMITED
INTELLIGENCE OPERATIONS, LIMITED
COUNTERTERRORISM OPERATIONS,
THEY DON'T PROVIDE INCOME FOR
THE MILITARY-INDUSTRIAL COMPLEX,
SO YOU'RE HEARING ALL THESE
FOLKS, THE SO-CALLED ADULTS IN
THE ROOM, THE SO-CALLED EXPERTS
IN WASHINGTON, D.C., SAYING NOW
WE ACCEPT THE FACT THAT WE ARE A
POWER INTO CLIENT AND WE RELY ON
ALL THESE OTHER POWERS AND
DECLINE IN THIS IS JUST THE WAY
THAT IT IS, UNLESS WE GO BACK
IN.
THAT IS THE PROBLEM RIGHT NOW
THAT WE HAVE.
WE ARE PRESENTED WITH THIS
BINARY CHOICE THAT IS ABSOLUTELY
FALSE, IT'S EXACTLY WHAT I AM
RUNNING FOR CONGRESS, TO CHANGE
THIS AND BRING SOME
ACCOUNTABILITY TO
WASHINGTON, D.C.
>> Brian: THE GOOD NEWS IS OUR
COMMANDERS DO NOT LIVE UP TO
WHAT OUR FIGHTERS DESERVE AND
THEY ARE READY TO GO AND WE HAVE
THE BEST PEOPLE ON THE PLANET,
WE DON'T HAVE FAR TO G